ich hoffe jetzt auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 8 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundeskanzler zum ausserordentlichen
europäischen rat am 30 und 31 mai für
die aussprache im anschluss an diese
regierungserklärung sind 90 minuten
vereinbart
und das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat nun der
bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
[Musik]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
der frieden ist nun selbstverständlich
krieg ist unvorstellbar geworden
zehn jahre ist es her dass der damalige
präsident des europäischen rats herman
van rompuy diese sätze gesprochen hat in
oslo war das bei der verleihung des
friedensnobelpreises an die europäische
union
herman van rompoy worte waren damals
natürlich auf die lage im innern der
europäischen union gemünzt und in der
tat krieg zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union ist auch heute
unvorstellbar das ist und bleibt die
größte errungenschaft der europäischen
einigung
doch beim blick auf die ruinen von mario
pohl die hier oder zac efron gedanken
denken an die massen gedanken die
massengräber von butter oder posthum l
bei den bildern zerschossene häuser
zertrümmerte autos und lebloser körper
unschuldiger frauen männer und kinder
wird schmerzhaft bewusst
krieg ist eben nicht überall
unvorstellbar geworden auch in europa
nicht
und frieden ist nur dann
selbstverständlich
wenn wir bereit sind ihn zu verteidigen
[Musik]
dass das die lehre die wir aus russlands
brutalen angriff auf die ukraine ziehen
darin mit die zeitenwende von der ich
ende februar hier in diesem haus
gesprochen habe liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unterschiedliche
herausforderungen und krisen hat die
europäische union in den letzten jahren
bewältigt der krieg in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft ist ohne
jeden zweifel die größte
in einem aber er findet auch diese krise
den vorangegangenen einmal mehr erleben
wir je größer der druck von außen des
desto entschlossener und geeinter
handelt die europäische union
weil der von putin entfachte krieg allem
widerspricht wofür diese union steht die
europäische union ist ein
friedensprojekt geboren aus der idee den
krieg und die feindschaft zwischen den
völkern europas ein für alle mal zu
überwinden
und so länder sind offen frei und
demokratisch
anders als putins autokratie
und wir begegnen uns mit respekt und in
dem wissen dass ausgleich und
kompromissbereitschaft keine schwächen
sind sondern es darin unsere stärke
liegt
mit dieser haltung werden wir die
europäische union fortentwickeln und
dabei ihre geschlossenheit war
auch emanuel makro hat das bei seinem
besuch letzte woche bekräftigt ich bin
dem französischen präsidenten daher sehr
dankbar dass ihn seine erste reise nach
der wiederwahl hierher nach berlin
geführt hat darin liegt auch ein
bekenntnis zur deutsch französischen
zusammenarbeit die stets mehr war als
ein bilaterales projekt ihre auflage er
wirklich darin lösung für die zukunft zu
finden die für alle
mitgliedstaaten tragen
das muss immer der antrieb sein des
deutsch-französischen motor die
zeitenwende erfordert dass wir auch in
europa über den tag hinaus denken dabei
werden wir anknüpfen an die vielen guten
vorschläge die die europäischen
bürgerinnen und bürger im rahmen der
zukunftskonferenz entwickelt haben am
europatag heute vor zehn tagen haben sie
die ergebnisse vorgestellt
den bürgern und bürgern geht es um eine
bürgernahe und effizientere union das
wird auch unser fokus
viele der vorschläge sind ganz konkret
die bürgerinnen und bürger wünschen sich
zum beispiel mehr konsequenz beim
klimaschutz fortschritte bei der
europäischen verteidigung ein
gerechteres und inklusives europa mit
mehr sozialen miteinander
vieles davon kann schnell umgesetzt
werden dafür braucht es keine
langwierigen änderung der verträge dazu
reichen gute vorschläge der kommission
das gilt auch für viele ideen um die eu
effizienter zu machen wie die von uns
geforderten mehrheitsentscheidungen im
rat gerade hier sehe ich dass sich in
den letzten wochen und monaten immer
mehr dieser idee anschließen gut so
wenn die sache es erfordert dann können
wir über eine änderung der verträge
reden auch über ein konvent dass es kein
tabu wichtig aber ist dass wir dabei
größtmöglich konsens erzielen denn wenn
wir eines nicht brauchen in dieser zeit
dann ist das eine kontroverse zeit und
energie raubende nabelschau zu
institutionellen fragen
das ginge auch an den erwartungen vorbei
die die bürgerinnen und bürger an ein
funktionierendes europa haben die
zeitenwende betrifft auch euro brauchen
deshalb ja wir werden die eu weiter
entwickeln und genauso mutig und
entschlossen wie unsere nationale
antwort wird auch unser europäische
antwort darauf ausfallen
mit diesem ziel werde ich in zehn tagen
zum sondertreffen der staats und
regierungschefs nach brüssel reisen
deutschlands rolle dabei ist für mich
ganz klar als größtes land tragen wir
besondere verantwortung für die
einigkeit der europäischen union und
mehr noch selten zuvor war unsere
zusammenarbeit mit den
wirtschaftsstarken demokratien den g7 so
effektiv und so intensiv wie in diesen
tagen und wochen unter unserem vorsitz
deshalb blicke ich auch voll zuversicht
auf unser gipfeltreffen ende juni in elm
und
selten zuvor war das transatlantische
bündnis so eng so lebendig und so
essentiell wie heute präsident biden hat
großen anteil daran und dafür bin ich
sehr dankbar
uns alle eint ein ziel russland darf
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen die ukraine
muss bestehen
darum geht es darum geht es bei allem
was wir tun bei unseren sanktionen gegen
russland bei der aufnahme millionen
geflüchteter in der europäischen union
bei der humanitären
entwicklungspolitischen und
wirtschaftlichen unterstützung der
ukraine
und ja auch bei der lieferung von waffen
einschließlich schwerem gerät
ich weiß das ist nicht unumstritten in
unserem land auch sie erleben in ihren
wahlkreisen sich viele kontroverse
diskussion sie bekommen zuschriften von
bürgerinnen und bürgern die sich sorgen
machen mir geht es nicht anders
wandern gehen unsere unterstützung nicht
weit genug andere wiederum geht sie viel
zu weit und nahezu alle bürgerinnen und
bürger ein die sorge um den frieden in
der ukraine aber auch hier bei uns
ich will daher eines ganz deutlich sagen
einem brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen darin liegt keine
eskalation
sondern ein beitrag dazu den angriff
abzuwehren
und damit schnellstmöglich die gewalt zu
beenden
noch immer glaubt putin dass er einen
diktat frieden herbeibomben kann
doch er irrt sich
so wie er sich schon im blick auf die
entschlossenheit der ukraine ukraine und
die geschlossenheit unserer bündnisse
und allianzen geirrt hat
einen diktat frieden wird es nicht geben
weil die ukraine ukraine ihnen nicht
akzeptieren und wir auch nicht
erst wenn putin das begreift erst wenn
er versteht dass er die verteidigung der
ukraine nicht brechen kann dann wird er
bereit seien ernsthaft über frieden zu
verhandeln
deshalb stärken wir die ukraine den
rücken auch militärisch wir tun das
überlegt abgewogen und international eng
abgestimmt und es bleibt bei dem was ich
den bürgerinnen und bürgern am 8 mai
gesagt habe es wird keine deutschen
alleingänge geben alles was wir tun muss
russland mehr schaden und zu selbst und
unseren partnern die unternehmen nichts
was die nato zur kriegspartei werden
lässt und
wir werden unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit sichern und
stärken
dafür braucht die bundeswehr das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
wir sind dazu in guten gesprächen auch
mit ihrer partei die bei herz und das
sondervermögen fest im grundgesetz zu
verankern dafür bin ich dankbar
denn so bringen wir gemeinsam zum
ausdruck regierung und opposition wir
stellen uns unserer staatspolitischen
verantwortung
das sondervermögen garantiert freiheit
und sicherheit unseres landes in dieser
schwierigen zeit und mehr noch mit dem
sondervermögen senden wir eine klare
botschaft an freunde und verbündete ja
wir meinen es ernst wenn wir von
beistandspflicht und kollektive
verteidigung reden
ja das bevölkerungsreichste und
wirtschaftsstärksten nationen europas
leistet deutschland dazu seinen
angemessenen beitrag
das erwarten unsere freunde und
ernährten von uns im rahmen der nato
ziele und dazu sind wir bereit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn wir wissen
es ist diese bereitschaft dieses
bekenntnis einer für alle und alle für
einen das unser transatlantisches
bündnis trägt
welch großem wert diese gewissheit hat
was zeigt der wunsch schwedens und
finnlands sich der nato anzuschließen
und ich sage ohne jedes zögern liebe
freundinnen und freunde in schweden und
finnland ihr seid uns herzlich
willkommen mit euch an unserer seite
wird die sache
russlands angriff auf die ukraine hat
auch viele andere länder europas dazu
gebracht neu über ihre sicherheit ans
nachzudenken viele investieren seither
deutlich mehr in ihre verteidigung oft
standen dabei unsere entscheidung
partner umso wichtiger ist es dass wir
diese nun mit dem sondervermögen
umsätzen
auf eines werden wir dabei achten unsere
verteidigungssystem und unsere
investitionen müssen auch europäisch
enger koordiniert und besser aufeinander
abgestimmt werden wir alle wissen
wir alle wissen seit jahren um die teure
und ineffiziente vielzahl
unterschiedlichster waffensystem in
europa so kann es nicht weitergehen
deshalb wollen wir unsere
technologischen möglichkeiten stärker
gemeinsam nutzen und die europäische
verteidigungsindustrie enger verzahnt
über die notwendigen schritte werden wir
beim sondergipfel ende des monats
beraten es geht um mehr effizienz und
mehr komplementarität
und nicht zuletzt geht es angesichts der
russischen bedrohung auch darum jetzt
einen großen schritt richtung zukunft zu
gehen zu einer gemeinsamen europäischen
verteidigung die eine starke säule
innerhalb der nato bleibt
den blick voraus zu werfen
heißt auch sich in sachen ukraine weiter
zu unterhalten
hoffentlich früher als später wird der
krieg enden und schon jetzt ist klar der
wiederaufbau der zerstörten
infrastruktur die wiederbelebung der
ukrainischen wirtschaft all das wird
milliarden kosten
daher müssen wir als europäische union
jetzt die vorarbeiten für einen
solidaritätsfonds beginn der sich aus
beiträgen der eu und unserer
internationalen partner speist
damit werden wir den ukrainern
dann helfen die zerstörung zu beseitigen
die der krieg hinterlässt solidarisch
als europäische freunde und nachbarn
bereits beim treffen der staats- und
regierungschefs in passeier haben wir
klar gesagt die ukraine ist teil unserer
europäischen familie
das gilt mit dem solidaritätsfonds
werden wir sie auf ihrem europäischen
weg unterstützen und dabei
rechtsstaatlichkeit gute
regierungsführung und die demokratie
stärken
die ukraine hat beantragt mitglied der
europäischen union zu werden die
kommission wird vor dem europäischen rat
voraussichtlich ende juni ihre
einschätzung zu dem antrag abgeben
und zugleich wissen wir alle
immer nur im agro hat recht wenn er
darauf hinweist dass der
beitrittsprozess keine sache von ein
paar monaten oder einigen jahren ist und
deshalb wollen wir uns jetzt darauf
konzentrieren die ukraine schnell und
pragmatisch zu unterstützen über den
besten weg dafür werde ich mit meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen beraten
dass es auf dem weg in die eu keine
abkürzungen gibt ist auch ein gebot der
fairness gegenüber den sechs ländern des
westlichen balkan
seit jahren unternehmen sie intensive
reformen und bereiten sich auf den
beitritt vor
dass wir unsere zusagen gegenüber
einhalten ist nicht nur eine frage
unserer glaubwürdigkeit
heute mehr denn je diktiere integration
auch in unserem strategischen interesse
es geht nicht allein um die sicherheit
dieser region in der externe kräfte um
einfluss ringen nicht zuletzt russland
es geht um unsere eigene sicherheit die
ohne einen stabilen europäischen
westbalkan nicht zu haben ist
daher muss auch die eu jetzt gegen
liefern gegenüber dem westlichen balkan
und dafür setze ich mich ein indem ich
gespräche führe um fortschritte bei den
verhandlungen zu erreichen und auch
innerhalb der eu die letzten hindernisse
auf dem weg zu hören indem wir den
sogenannten berliner prozess
wiederbeleben der die regionale
zusammenarbeit unter den sechs
westbalkanstaaten stärkt und in dem ich
noch vor dem europäischen rat im juni in
die region reisen mit der klaren
botschaft im gepäck der westliche balkan
gehört in die europäische union
viele kollegen kollegen ein weiteres
thema wird uns bei unserem gipfel in
zehn tagen intensiv beschäftigen und
auch viele bürgerinnen und bürger treibt
es um es geht um die sicherheit und
unabhängigkeit unserer energieversorgung
es geht um bezahlbare energie beides
müssen wir gewährleisten
national und europäisch und sowohl
national als auch europäisch behalten
wir eines immer im blick dass der von
russland verschuldete preisanstieg
niemanden überfordert wir lassen
niemanden allein
das gilt ganz besonders für die
bürgerinnen und bürger mit kleinem und
mittlerem einkommen
sie spüren tagtäglich das durch den
krieg nicht nur der sprit an der
zapfsäule teurer geworden ist sondern
auch lebensmittel vom brot bis zum
speise und
auch betriebe die unter den
energiepreisen leiden und denen die
russland geschäft weggebrochen es können
sich auf unsere unterstützung verlassen
dafür stehen die beiden entlastungspaket
die wir schon beschlossen haben und die
in den nächsten wochen wirken die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage die energie
pauschale von 300 euro die zuschüsse für
familien wohngeldempfänger studierende
und sozialleistungsempfänger die
entlastung beim tanken das neun euro
ticket als anreiz stärker den
öffentlichen nahverkehr zu nutzen all
das kommt den bürgern und bürgern zugute
direkt schnell und zielgerichtet
und für die unterstützung dieser
maßnahmen durch den bundestag sage ich
herzlich danke
auf europäischer ebene geht es vor allem
darum sicherzustellen dass es keine
engpässe bei der energieversorgung in
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten gibt das ist
ein gebot europäischer solidarität
teil einer europäischen lösung ist daher
auch der ausbau der transeuropäischen
energienetze
mittel und langfristig bleibt der einzig
vernünftige weg die einzig vernünftige
antwort auf die derzeitigen probleme am
energiemarkt dass wir uns unabhängig
machen von fossiler energie
dass wir dadurch gemeinsam vorankommen
in europa hat mein gestriges treffen mit
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen aus
dänemark den niederlanden belgien und
kommissionspräsidentin von allein im
dänischen esbjerg gezeigt
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck und
ich haben mit unseren kolleginnen
kollegen vereinbart die gewinnung und
nutzung von windenergie in der nordsee
gemeinsam noch viel stärker
voranzutreiben
die kommissionspräsident und hat dabei
ihre vorschläge erneut hat um europa
unabhängiger von fossilen
energieimporten aus russland zu machen
und den übergang zur klimaneutralität
voranzubringen das ist eine wichtige
initiative der kommission
wir werden uns die vorschläge jetzt
ansehen und dabei über beim
außerordentlichen europäischen rat
beraten wir wollen dass davon impulse
ausgehen zur beschleunigung des ausbaus
der erneuerbaren energien für mehr
energieeffizienz und für die
industrielle transformation auf
das kit objektiv paket der eu spielt
hier eine entscheidende rolle es muss
vollständig verabschiedet werden so
schnell wie möglich unser ziel ist klar
wir wollen und wir werden die
souveränität europas auch in
energiefragen erhöhen und europas
klimaziele erreichen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nicht nur
an dieser stelle zeigt sich wie
tiefgreifend die folgen des russischen
krieges sind weit über die
sicherheitspolitik hinaus bei der
energieversorgung bei den
rohstoffpreisen
bei der weltweiten versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln
viele länder in der welt müssen sich
sorgen machen wie das weitergeht
angesichts des kriegs in der ukraine und
in vielen anderen bereichen unseres
lebens
ich habe daher schon zu beginn des
russischen anders gesagt die folgen
dieses krieges treffen auch uns und
zugleich bin ich fest davon überzeugt
wir werden die folgen bewältigen hier
bei uns in europa und auch weltweit
weil wir ein starkes land sind mit
starken partnern und allianzen vor allem
aber weil wir wissen was wir verteidigen
frieden freiheit und
recht schönen dunk
war
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich werde mich nicht ein rein in eine
gruppe von leuten die für ein kurzes
rein und raus mit einem fototermin was
machen
das war
rund 20 tat zwar ein zitat des
bundeskanzlers aus einem interview auf
die frage wann er denn jetzt nach kiew
reisen wollte herr bundeskanzler wen
meinen sie denn mit dieser gruppe von
leuten
meinen sie damit
bei ihnen liegen aber nach dem letzten
wahlsonntag die nerven wird nicht lang
frage sie noch mal bundeskanzler will
meinen sie damit sind ja jetzt immerhin
keine jungs und mädels mehr die sie da
apostrophieren sondern eine gruppe von
leuten also ist dass die
bundestagspräsidentin oder sind das die
drei ausschussvorsitzenden ist dass der
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
ist dass nancy pelosi die sprecherin des
amerikanischen repräsentantenhauses sind
das die ministerpräsidenten aus polen
tschechien und slowenien oder ist es
etwa die bundesministerin die heute aus
guten gründen hier nicht dabei sein kann
sie sprechen immer so viel auch in ihrer
rede heute von respekt ich möchte an
dieser stelle einfach denjenigen die aus
deutschland der bundes außenministerin
und der bundestagspräsidentin einmal
herzlich dank sagen und respekt
ausdrücken dass sie diese reise gemacht
haben herzlich dankbar
auch aufschlussreich das kann nur die
unionsfraktion jetzt klatscht mich aber
gut meine damen und herren die ukraine
braucht auch weiterhin die solidarität
der internationalen staatengemeinschaft
und das haben sie herr bundeskanzler mit
ihrer regierungserklärung heute richtig
und zutreffend zum ausdruck gebracht
dass brutale morgen an der bevölkerung
der ukraine und die sinnlose zerstörung
dieses landes durch die russischen
aggression gehen täglich weiter wir
begreifen jeden tag mehr wie furchtbar
dieser krieg ist und wie tief greifend
er die politische ordnung nicht nur in
europa sondern auf der ganzen welt
verändern wird vor diesem hintergrund
ist es gut und richtig dass die staats
und regierungschefs der europäischen
union in der übernächsten woche zu einem
außerordentlichen treffen zusammenkommen
der deutsche bundestag hat ihnen der
bundeskanzler auf dem weg dorthin in der
gemeinsamen entschließung die wir mit
großer mehrheit am 28 april
verabschiedet haben einen klaren
beschluss gegeben eine grundlage gegeben
welche schritte wir aus der mitte des
parlaments hier in deutschland für
richtig und für notwendig halten wir
wollen und wir müssen dem land
finanziell und humanitär
weiterhelfen und ich will an dieser
stelle
[Musik]
ein herzliches danke sagen an alle
humanitären organisationen in
deutschland aber auch an die vielen
familien die geflüchtete frauen mütter
mit ihren kindern aufnehmen in schutz
und zuflucht in deutschland gewähren
dies ist ein großartiges zeichen unseres
blattes
wir wollen einvernehmen hier in diesem
haus mit sanktionen dafür sorgen dass
dieses putin regime regime getroffen
wird dass der gesamte militärisch
industrielle komplex dieses landes so
hart wie möglich getroffen wird und
meine damen und herren ja auch das ist
konsens hier in diesem haus jedenfalls
in der politischen mitte dieses hauses
wir wollen und wir müssen der ukraine
mit waffen helfen damit dieses land sein
recht zur selbstverteidigung wahrnehmen
kann nun stellen sich allerdings
in diesem zusammenhang herr
bundeskanzler eine ganze reihe von
fragen sie haben hier richtigerweise in
ihrer regierungserklärung betont dass
mit diesen waffen lieferungen an die
ukraine keine eskalation dieses
konfliktes verbunden sind die
einschätzung teilen wir aber warum sagen
sie denn in interviews mehrfach
hintereinander
genau diesen sachverhalt und männern
waffenlieferungen aus europa und aus
deutschland als eine mögliche gefährdung
einer eskalation das passt doch nicht
zusammen was sie heute morgen hier
gesagt haben und dass sie immer wieder
auch im internet zu diesem thema
und dann erwecken sie den eindruck dass
diese waffenlieferungen stattfinden die
wahrheit ist doch dass aus deutschland
in den letzten wochen so gut wie nichts
an waffen geliefert worden ist wir
wissen es doch wir können doch die
dokumente eins es wird praktisch nichts
geliefert stattdessen versprechen sie
dem gepard das ist ein waffensystem dass
die ukraine gar nicht haben wollte das
ist das komplizierteste waffensystem
dass es überhaupt gibt und für dieses
waffensystem gibt es keine munition was
machen sie denn was treiben sie denn da
für ein spiel auch mit der deutschen
öffentlichkeit wenn es um diese
waffenlieferungen
sie sprechen sagt wochen wir sprechen
seit wochen von einem so genannten ring
tag der da von statten gehen soll der
hat bis heute nicht stattgefunden
sie erklären dass unternehmen die noch
waffensysteme auf ihren höfen stehen
haben liefern dürfen seit wochen
beklagen diese unternehmen mittlerweile
öffentlich dass sie die
exportgenehmigungen der bundesregierung
für diese waffenlieferungen nicht kommen
was ist da eigentlich los welches
doppelte spiel wird da eigentlich in
ihrer regierung betrieben meine damen
und herren ich bin geneigt ich bin
geneigt herrnhofer hier nochmal zu
zitieren
finde in diesem zusammenhang ganz zu
unrecht gesagt hat das problem sitzt im
kanzleramt meine damen und herren und so
scheint es in der tat die sein
sie sprechen sie sprechen dann
gleichzeitig der
bundesverteidigungsministerium mit
ministerin ihr vertrauen aus einer
ministerin die seit wochen mehr mit
selbstverteidigung als mit
verteidigungspolitik beschäftigt ist und
am letzten wochenende am letzten
wochenende ist ein bericht in der presse
erschienen meine damen und herren der
nun endgültig belegt dass diese
ministerin das vertrauen der soldatinnen
und soldaten der bundeswehr nicht mehr
erreichen wird deswegen dem ich ihnen
den rat trennen sie sich von dieser
ministerin so schnell wie möglich sie
werden ist sowieso irgendwann in den
nächsten wochen und monaten machen
müssen also machen sie muss bald damit
es mit der bundeswehr auch wieder
wirklich voran gehen und vor diesem
hintergrund vor diesem hintergrund
werden sie verstehen dass wir im
zusammenhang mit dem vorschlag eines
sondervermögens über 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr besonders sorgfältig
umgehen ja wir sind in gesprächen ob das
gute gespräche sind zahlen war dahin
gestellt wir sind uns jedenfalls bisher
nicht einig gut sind sie nur in einer
hinsicht wir die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist die
einzige fraktion in diesem bundestag die
ihnen mit dem was sie gesagt haben in
ihrer regierungserklärung am 27 februar
nämlich 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr und dauerhaft mehr als zwei
prozent unseres bip in jedem jahr für
die verteidigung wir sind die einzige
fraktion die ihn in diesem weg
uneingeschränkt folgende den widerspruch
den gibt es auf ihren
regierungsfraktionen herr bundeskanzler
sie haben sie haben angesprochen in
ihrer regierungserklärung das
beschaffungs system wir sind uns mit
ihnen einig dass wir daran etwas
wirklich grundlegendes ändern müssen wir
können diese 100 milliarden nicht noch
einmal zu
wir sind uns einig mit ihnen was ist
denn daran auch zur aufregung wir sind
mit ihnen einig dass wir dieses
beschaffungs system ändern wollen ich
möchte nur heute fast drei monate
nachdem sie den vorschlag gemacht haben
einmal feststellen es gibt dazu aus
ihrer koalition bis heute keinen
einzigen vorschlag wie das denn gehen
soll also die beschwörung einer
notwendigkeit was da alles geändert
werden muss ist das eine aber praktische
politik in der richtigen kompetenzen des
bundeskanzlers sehen wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt bis heute nicht meine damen
und herren
und dann lassen wir ihnen abschließend
lost nämlich abschließend einige themen
ansprechen die sie nur am rande oder gar
nicht angesprochen haben ja wir sind der
meinung dass der westbalkan in die
europäische union aufgenommen werden
sollte wir sind mit ihnen der meinung
dass die ukraine eine
beitrittsperspektive haben muss in die
europäische union aber was sagt denn die
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland auf diese frage sind sie für
einen kandidatenstatus der ukraine oder
sind sie es nicht das wäre doch eine
gute gelegenheit gewesen dass heute
morgen hier mal in deutschland sie sagt
wie stehen sie
wie stehen sie zu dem wunsch der ukraine
nach diesem krieg den wir hoffentlich
bald zu ende gehen sehen
sicherheitsgarantien auch aus
deutschland zu bekommen sind sie bereit
solche sicherheits garantien zu geben ja
oder nein wie soll der wiederaufbau der
ukraine denn finanziert werden sie sagen
einen solidaritätsfonds damit können wir
uns durchaus anfreunden mit diesen
gedanken aber wie soll dieser
solidaritätsfonds denn finanziert werden
sind sie mit teilen der eu kommission
der auffassung dass dies mit
zusätzlichen neuen schulden der
europäischen union gemacht werden soll
oder sind sie dagegen sagen sie doch uns
ihre meinung zu diesen zentralen themen
um die es dann auch geht in der welt von
morgen nach diesem krieg und dann zwei
letzte anderen
der französische staatspräsident hat bei
seinem besuch hier in berlin ja
vorgeschlagen ein neues system der
integration der heranführung
verschiedener staaten an die europäische
union zu entwickeln er hat davon
gesprochen die demokratien der welt um
die europäische union herum zu einen wie
soll das denn gehen wir sind dafür dass
das stattfindet aber wie soll es denn
institutionell gehen sind sie der
meinung dass zum beispiel der
europäische wirtschaftsraum gestärkt
werden sollen dass die etliche weise ein
instrument sein könnte sind sie der
auffassung das assoziierungsabkommen mit
der europäischen union auf den weg
gebracht werden sollten um diese
heranführung an die europäische union zu
ermöglichen und dann haben sie über eine
zuständigkeit der europäischen union
überhaupt nicht gesprochen die sie
nämlich neben der währungspolitik fast
ganz alleine hat aber auf die zustimmung
der mitgliedstaaten angewiesen ist ja
kein wort über die handelspolitik
verloren meine damen und herren ja wir
brauchen energie wir brauchen gas wir
brauchen kohle wir brauchen öl aus
vielen anderen ländern der welt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister ist in katar
unterwegs um gaslieferungen nach
deutschland zu ermöglichen aber warum um
gottes willen lehnen sie bis in diese
woche hinein die befassung des deutschen
bundestages mit dem fertig gestellten
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada immer
wieder ab gestern
fester
bei dass sich die mehrheit ihrer
koalition
dieses abkommen auf die tagesordnung des
deutschen bundestages zu setzen es
weigert sich die mehrheit ihrer
koalition auch einmal über die frage zu
sprechen wie wir denn die
handelsbeziehungen zu den vereinigten
staaten von amerika weiterentwickeln
sollen mit katar gaslieferungen zu
machen und mit kanada kein abkommen
abzuschließen über den freihandel herr
bundeskanzler ihre politik wird nicht
glaubwürdiger dadurch dass es auf diese
art und weise zu lassen und schließlich
zum schluss sie verlieren kein wort sie
verlieren kein wort über den umgang der
europäischen union mit den zwei größten
ländern dieser welt nämlich mit indien
und mit china zwei länder die sich im
vereinten in der verein in der
vollversammlung der vereinten nationen
ihrer stimme enthalten haben als es um
die verurteilung der aggression in
russland ging wie soll diese europäische
union ihre beziehungen zu indien und
china den entwickeln angesichts dieser
weigerung sich auf die seite der
freiheitlichen und demokratischen
staaten der welt zu stellen darauf muss
europa doch eine antwort geben und
europa kann nur eine antwort geben dann
ist dazu eine vorstellung der
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland gibt ohne sie wird es nicht
gehen der bundeskanzler sie müssen dazu
etwas sagen
lassen
lassen sie nicht nur die
schlussfolgerung
denn wenn zeitenwende wirklich der
epochenwandel ist den sie in ihrer
regierungserklärung am 27 februar hier
von dieser stelle aus beschrieben haben
dann bleibt jedenfalls die heutige
regierungserklärung von ihnen weit
hinter den notwendigkeiten zurück um
eine solche epochenwende wirklich aktiv
zu gestalten
da muss mehr komponist anschlag das
reicht nicht zum letzten mal
da die versprochene zeitenwende gab es
sie jetzt ja oder nein friedrich merz
sagt nein und er hatte richtig
temperatur das kann man an dieser stelle
glaube ich sagen es ging direkt mal los
mit einem kräftigen seitenhieb auf den
kanzler denn noch immer nicht selbst in
der ukraine war und erteilt auch
weiterhin heftig aus zum thema
waffenlieferung zum beispiel er hat
gesagt es wird praktisch nichts
geliefert kritisierte er den kanzler und
fragte dann auch ganz konkret was
treiben sie für ein spiel mit der
deutschen öffentlichkeit wenn es um die
waffenlieferungen geht fragt er den
kanzler und dann hat er auch noch ganz
klar den rücktritt von
verteidigungsminister in lambrecht
gefordert also es gibt viel zu
besprechen dieser stelle sebastian
geisler ist hier bei uns aus der politik
schön dass du jedes lassen sich als
erstes mal über den kanzler reden denn
der hat deutliche worte gefunden
richtung kriegstreiber putin es werde
keinen diktat frieden geben was genau
meint er machte einfach damit dass man
nicht akzeptieren werde dass putin
sozusagen einen frieden diktiert in dem
sinne von putin sagt wir besiegen putin
besiegt die ukraine und dann erklärt
putin den krieg für beendet hat die
ukraine besetzt das darf es nicht geben
sondern ist soll hier offenbar zu einer
situation kommen dass man russland auch
zurückschlägt und dass sich akzeptieren
wird dass putin einfach sich selbst zum
sieger erklärt und damit die ukraine als
nation im grunde oder als als stadt
auslöscht scholz wurde ja in den letzten
wochen auch sehr häufig kritisiert dass
er sich nicht klar positionieren würde
war das für dich heute eine klartext
rede ich meine hat sich ja auch zu
vielen dingen wirklich gut bekannt zum
beispiel zum nato-beitritt von finnland
und schweden hat er gesagt ihr seid mit
uns sicher also er sagt ganz klar ja er
steht hinter diesen beiden ländern und
hinter dieser entscheidung ja hat sogar
einen willkommenen den beiden ländern
ausgesprochen also für seine
verhältnisse was tatsächlich klartext
rede in der er auch ein paar punkte
angesprochen hat die tatsächlich jetzt
auf der agenda stehen er hat zum
beispiel auch die ukraine auch das im
klartext wort als teil der europäischen
familie bezeichnet hat dann wiederum
erwartungen etwas gedämpft was den weg
in einen möglichen eu-beitritt angeht
hat gesagt also man kann da sozusagen
jetzt auch das nicht mehr beschleunigen
als man gegenüber den balkanstaaten
auftritt er hat das sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr noch mal angesprochen die
100 milliarden hat eigentlich sogar
angekündigt dass die europäische
verteidigungspolitik eigentlich und
außenpolitik neu aufgestellt werden muss
in dem sinne dass man waffensysteme
miteinander koordiniert das hat er als
bislang teuer und ineffizient
bezeichnet also auch da scheint er jetzt
reformen möglicherweise anstoßen zu
wollen er hat den anderen punkten aber
muss man jetzt mal kritisieren aber auch
die rede genutzt ein bisschen schuld
abzuschieben also er hat beispielsweise
ein innenpolitisches signal gesendet und
den menschen gesagt den bürgern die
spüren jetzt an der zapfsäule wie durch
putins angriffskrieg alles teurer wird
das ist natürlich wirklich nur ein teil
der wahrheit also diese kosten kommen
jetzt dazu zu etwas was aber zum
beispiel durch energiewende durch co2
preisaufschlag da vorher ja durch
deutsches regierungshandeln verursacht
wurde das hat mir an der stelle dann
nicht sehr gefallen und er hat ja auch
gesagt bezahlbare energie wird
gewährleistet kann man das glauben
ist die frage also in deutschland daran
festhält zum beispiel die letzten drei
atomkraftwerke abzuschalten habe ich da
meine zweifel er hat jetzt angekündigt
er will windkraft weiter ausbauen das
sind wiederum dinge die kennen wir schon
die erneuerbaren weiter ausbauen also
für fraglich bezahlbar ist ja auch ein
dehnbarer begriff sebastian geisler
vielen herzlichen dank für deinen besuch
hier im studio wir haben hier live
verfolgt die regierungserklärung von
bundeskanzlerin gerade im bundestag und
auch einen heftigen angriffen von der
opposition ließ friedrich merz